I'm a day after Dwight Clark's passing a
good friend of mine as well as Dwight
Clark's man who I love Steve Mariucci
here on the show how are you Steve hey
where are you doing time no I know my
condolences to you and your wife and
everybody else on the passing of Dwight
I gave you the floor about what he who
he was as a man Steve geez well you know
when you when you uh look back I think
right now for me anyway it was the most
recent memories I have is this past
weekend and so Gayle and I had a chance
to go up there and you know he is kind
of funny rich he he lived here in the
Bay Area in Capitola and and so and I
think you knew this that the guys you
know you read the book Tuesdays with
Maurey by Mitch Albom right and so we
had Tuesdays with Dwight and there would
be 10 15 20 guys on Tuesdays going over
to Capitola and having lunch with Dwight
and it was a spectacular it was story
time and it was reminiscing about you
know playing days and everything else
and and it was as much therapy for us as
it was for delight because you know he
would perk up he'd be having some bad
days at times and and then he'd start
smiling and telling stories and we'd all
be laughing and you know knowing that
you don't know how many more days Harry
no Steve I knew this would be emotional
for you and I but I also knew that you
knew Dwight better than most and and I
wanted to give you some time to to have
here on the show to talk about him I
mean when you fell
what did it when you first met him was
that when you first took the
forty-niners job Steve was that the
first no madam I you know we all knew
who delight Clark was when he made the
catch and he began really began at 49er
dynasty and that was the start of
something really really special in the
national
football league and we all know that and
how many times have we seen that call in
that play and to go ahead 28 27 over the
Cowboys with 51 seconds left I was
watching that as a fan back in 81 and we
all were um but I I and I met him a
couple times but we became friends when
I became the head coach because he was
the GM of the 49ers okay I'll tell you
what boy was he good he was a worker you
know he won rich two Super Bowl rings as
a player and he was the leading you know
we all remember the catch but he was the
leading receiver of the 49ers the
history of the 49ers when he retired you
know Jerry Rice came in they dropped to
Jerry Rice to play with the white Clark
opposite Dwight and then do I got hurt
and eventually retired and then Jerry
went on he's a man but it wasn't until
Jerry and T Oh at all those numbers that
Dwight's records were beaten but we
became very close then and and you know
we're the same age and and same
generation listen to the same music and
and really got along very well and and
as you recall he ended up leaving him
going to the Cleveland Browns with
Carmen policies right and and help that
organization start up again but we
remain very good friends all the way
through yeah I was with him this weekend
um he told us their momma lunches he
said hey um I'm going to be moving and
what any and he you know he's a bear
while he's from Carolina but he's been
in the Bay Area for so long and this is
his home and he says I'm gonna be moving
and we were kind of like why what are
you talking about and he says yeah we're
gonna go to Montana and live up there
and you'd be close to Eddie DeBartolo
and we're gonna get a you know some
acreage and place for horses and dogs to
run around and quiet and I and we we
never really got
good explanation from him other than you
know he wanted to Kelly his wife enjoys
that kind of lifestyle too maybe it was
to get away from you know a lot of
people and he Richie was deteriorating
pretty quickly and so about a month ago
we moved up there and so I just thought
that you know Galen I [ __ ] let's go
let's go see him because we're gonna we
have plans to be up there fourth of July
and mr. DeBartolo it throws a 4th of
July party and for her friends and
family it's huge and we were thinking
we'd see Dwight then too but I just I
just felt we needed to see him sooner
than that and I'm glad we did because he
was he was not in good shape
he in fact after we left I called mr.
Dean said hey you know I'm really
worried about him and he came over and
ended up having hospice care of that
afternoon so well then I mean Steve
Bucci Ron the Rich Eisen show for a
couple more minutes let's let's tell a
good one of those stories that made you
laugh we're showing while you were
telling these stories well we are seeing
all the photographs on our TV side of
these Tuesdays with Dwight where you and
a whole bunch of guys are getting around
and you are you're smiling and laugh and
in some one of these pictures what what
what well you got a wife when you didn't
want to talk about thee you didn't want
to talk about ALS much you know you even
he filled us in on his physicals but the
reason we got there together and guys
would fly in you got be white B what I
came in from Miami garrison Hearst came
em guys came from all over and and to
see I'm all over the place and it was
fun and it was story time and it was he
makes us laugh we make him laugh and for
a couple hours it's a it's a diversion I
guess um so it was good for everybody I
guess you know I remembered him you know
its competitive he's he was on the
football field he was he was that way as
a general manager
- and whites you know his language
godhand once lost
and I walked down to his office one time
and he was screaming at some guy don't
hurt em packager he was screaming at him
and I walked in and the guy was trying
to get every pound of flesh on a trade
from him and he was and then he hung up
the phone and he put his head on his
desk and he was exhausted I walked it I
started laughing because I said oh my
god I was a good one I wish I had up
didn't have cell phones back there not
going to record it would have been
classic but he was there every single
day I mean I you know every single day
Friday Saturday's the little
walkthroughs he was there with me every
single thing we ever did and I just I
told him many times he was the
hardest-working general manager by far
I've ever seen you know with me he was
just so committed to the 49er
organization God was he loved rich you
know I don't know when when I go or
maybe maybe when you go you know we'll
have Tuesdays with a rich or something I
don't know but he had so many friends
for so long I wanted to come and see him
and and we would have kept doing that if
he'd lived for another 10 or 20 years it
was just he was so loved by so many
people mooch I love you and Gail and I
appreciate I know this is rough but I
appreciate you bringing to as many
people as possible the love that Dwight
felt and that you feel for him you take
care you know that smooch Steve Mariucci
I knew I'll be rough what a brotherhood
huh a brotherhood men and women coming
together
rest in peace Dwight Clark